foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the 1960s was a decade that started off
screaming psycho titillated audiences
showing Janet Lee in a bra before
serving up one of the most shocking
death scenes ever committed to screen it
still shocks some 60 years later both
psycho and peeping Tom release the same
year and both share comment on voyeurism
with the latter going as far as
implicating the viewer in its POV murder
shots introducing such a lured concept
was enough to keep peeping Tom pulled
from theaters and all but kill director
Michael Powell's career with the
introduction of the Oscar for best
foreign language film in the late 40s
genre movies from abroad began to light
up theaters this includes horror
classics like Eyes Without a Face and
quaden
[Music]
thank you
by 1968 the haze code which delineated
what violent sex and themes could be
depicted on American screens was all but
gone and that same year the Night of the
Living Dead birthed a new age of
independent cinema and the zombie genre
itself speaking of birth Rosemary's Baby
also came out in 68 capping a decade of
memorable psychological thrillers like
the Innocents and whatever happened to
Baby Jane for this list we included
titles with at least 10 reviews and
according to their score and average
review are ranked by adjusted Tomato
Meter so get ready for some classic
screams as we count down our list of the
best horror movies of the 1960s
foreign
[Music]
taking its title from an archaic
Japanese word meaning ghost story this
Anthology adapts four folk tales a
penniless Samurai marries for money with
tragic results a man stranded in a
blizzard is saved by Yuki the snow
Maiden but his rescue comes at a cost
blind musician hoichi is forced to
perform for an audience of ghosts an
author relates the story of a samurai
who sees another Warrior's reflection in
his teacup starring katsuo Nakamura
rentaro Mikuni Keiko Kishi and directed
by masaki Kobayashi critics say
exquisitely designed and fastidiously
ornate masaki kobayashi's ambitious
Anthology cuaden operates less as a
frightening example of horror and more
as a meditative tribute to Japanese
folklore
foreign
thank you
number nine persona famed Sage stress
Elizabeth Vogler suffers a moment of
blankness during her performance and the
next day lapses into total silence
advised by her doctor to take time off
to recover from what appears to be an
emotional breakdown Elizabeth goes to a
beach house on the Baltic Sea with only
Alma a nurse his company over the next
several weeks is Alma struggles to reach
her mute patient the two women find
themselves experiencing a strange
emotional convergence starring Bibi
Anderson Liv Ullman Gunner Yorn Strand
and directed by ingmar Bergman critics
say arguably bergman's finest film
Persona explores a human condition with
intense curiosity immense technical
skill and beguiling warmth
at least
Elizabeth
foreign
number eight whatever happened to Baby
Jane Jane Hudson is an aging child star
left to care for her wheelchair-bound
sister Blanche also a former child
actress stuck living together in a
mansion in old Hollywood Blanche plots
to get even with Jane for the car crash
it left her crippled years earlier but
Jane is desperate to keep Blanche
imprisoned as she plans a new rise to
fame and tries to hide blanche's
existence from doctors visitors and
neighbors while she devises a way to get
rid of her sister starring Betty Davis
Joan Crawford Victor buono and directed
by Robert Aldrich critics say whatever
happened to Baby Jane combines
Powerhouse acting Rich atmosphere and
absorbing melodrama in service of a
taught Thriller with thought-provoking
subtexts who was that at the door
earlier Elvira
where is she now in the kitchen
No I gave her the day off
it's a pretty hard time considering
I told her to come back next week
I'll plan
you know we got rats in the cellar
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
number seven the birds
Melanie Daniels meets Mitch Brenner in a
San Francisco pet store and decides to
follow him home she brings with her the
gift of two lovebirds and they strike up
a romance one day birds start attacking
children at Mitch's sister's party and
eventually a huge assault starts on the
town for more attacking Birds starring
Rod Taylor Tippy hedron Suzanne
Pleshette and directed by Alfred
Hitchcock critics say proving once again
that buildup is the key to suspense
Alfred Hitchcock successfully turned
Birds into some of the most terrifying
villains in Horror history in the birds
I want you to go as quietly as possible
do not make a sound until I tell you to
run then run as quickly as you can not
as everybody understand
all right John you lead the way
[Applause]
required
[Applause]
number six the Innocents
based on the Henry James story the turn
of the screw a psychological Thriller
about a woman who takes a governess job
for two orphans in a Victorian home she
begins to see what she believes or goes
and suspects the children's bizarre
behavior is the result of Supernatural
Powers starring Deborah Kerr Martin
Stevens Pamela Franklin and directed by
Jack Clayton critics say creepily
atmospheric the innocence is a stylishly
crafted chilling British ghost tale with
Deborah Kerr at her finest and win
did you first see and hear of such
things
I made them up
who taught them to you
he told you they just came into my head
what were they
shall I tell you who taught them to you
I will never again I promise shall I
tell you who taught you the things
you've done the things you've said shall
I tell you his name you don't fool me I
know why you keep on and on it's because
you're afraid you're afraid you might be
mad so you keep on and on trying to make
me admit something that isn't true
trying to fight me the way you frighten
Flora
I know baby you think you can run to my
uncle with a lot of lies but he won't
believe you not when I tell him what you
are a damn hussy a damn dirty-minded hag
you'll never fooled us we always knew
haha number five peeping Tom loner Mark
Lewis works at a film studio during the
day and at night takes racy photographs
of women also he's making a documentary
on fear which involves recording the
reactions of victims as he murders them
he befriends Helen the daughter of the
family living in the apartment below his
and he tells her vaguely about the movie
he's making she sneaks into Mark's
apartment to watch it and is horrified
by what she sees especially when Mark
catches her starring Carl Heinz mom
Moira Shearer Anna Massey and directed
by Michael Powell critics say peeping
Tom is a chilling methodical look at the
psychology of a killer and a classic
work of voyeuristic Cinema
all right
now
[Music]
Number Four Eyes Without a Face
Dr Jen essiers riddled with Guild after
an accident that he caused disfigures
the face of his daughter the once
beautiful Christian who Outsiders
believe is dead Dr Jenna Sierra along
with accomplice and laboratory assistant
Louise kidnaps young women and brings
them to the genesier mansion after
rendering his victims unconscious Dr
Jenna Sierra removes her faces and
attempts to graft them onto Christians
starring Pierre brosor Elita volley Edis
Cobb and directed by George franju
critics say a horrific tale of guilt and
Obsession Eyes Without a Face is just as
chilling and poetic today as it was when
it first released
foreign
foreign
[Music]
number three Rosemary's Baby
why fish Rosemary Woodhouse and her
struggling actor husband guy moved to a
New York City apartment building with an
ominous reputation and odd neighbors
Roman and Minnie Costa vet when Rosemary
becomes pregnant she becomes
increasingly isolated and the Diabolical
truth is revealed only after Rosemary
gives birth starring Mia Farrow John
cassavetz Ruth Gordon and directed by
Roman Polanski critics say Rosemary's
Baby is a frightening tale of Satanism
and pregnancy that is even more
disturbing than it sounds thanks to
convincing and committed performances by
Mia Farrow and Ruth Gordon
[Music]
what have you done to it
what have you done to its eyes he has
his father's eyes
[Music]
you're bad guys
I see him you maniac Satan is his father
not guy
he came up from hell and begat a son of
mortal woman hail Satan Satan is his
father and his name is Adrian he shall
overthrow the mighty and lay waste their
temples he shall redeem the despised and
reap Vengeance in the name of the brain
and the tortured number two Night of the
Living Dead a disparate group of
individuals takes refuge in an abandoned
house when corpses begin to leave the
graveyard in search of fresh human
bodies to Devour the pragmatic Ben does
his best to control the situation but
when the reanimated bodies surround the
house the other survivors begin to panic
as any semblance of order within the
group begins to dissipate the zombies
start to find ways inside and One By One
The Living humans become the prey of the
deceased ones starring Dwayne Jones
Judith O'Day Carl Hardman and directed
by George A Romero critics say George a
Romero's debut Night of the Living Dead
set the template for the zombie film and
features tight editing realistic Gore
and a Sly political undercurrent stop it
you're ignorant they're coming for you
Barbara
stop it you're acting like a child
they're coming for you
look there comes one of them now
he'll hear you here he comes now I'm
getting out of here Johnny
[Music]
Johnny
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Village of the Damned one day the
peaceful Village of midwich is cast into
a mysterious sleep for several hours but
with no obvious consequences soon all
the women of childbearing age turn out
to be pregnant their children are all
born at the same time and grow quickly
into very spooky young people with
strange white blonde hair and Eerie eyes
starring George Sanders Barbara Shelley
Michael Gwynn and directed by wolf rilla
critics say chilling performances and a
restrained Eerie atmosphere make Village
of the Damned both an unnerving parable
of its era and a Timeless classic you're
not thinking of atomic energy
your thinking of
a brick wall
[Music]
and a stick of brick wall
s
[Music]
[Music]
the clothes
only a few seconds
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Rex van Wren arrive at a fashionable
party thrown by rushloe's Protege Simon
Aaron they soon realize that the party
is in fact a gathering of satanic cult
led by the high priest makata that plans
to initiate the beautiful tanith that
night it's up to durishlo and Van Wren
to defeat the Devil worshiping makata
and save innocent young tanith and the
others from a terrible fate starring
Christopher Lee Charles Gray Nike arigi
and directed by Terence Fisher Nyla
Scargill from Exquisite Terror says as a
classic tale of good versus evil the
film required a strong representative of
either side and does not disappoint
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
ready
[Music]
oh he's upstairs to sleep
[Music]
the sorcerers a professor and his wife
can feel the sensations of a mod British
teen whose mind they control starring
Boris Karloff Catherine Lacy Ian ogilvey
and directed by Michael Reeves variety
says Boris Karloff brings his familiar
adroit horror touch to the role of an
aging somewhat nutty x-stage mesmerist
who aims to complete his experiments by
dominating the brain of a young subject
well in this thing yeah sit down
I'm Too Young To Die you said you wanted
something new something you've never
done before yeah well I didn't think
that Johan will come to you we guarantee
it
what's it supposed to do
ghastly
Indescribable experience
complete abandonment with no sort of
remorse intoxication with no hangover
Ecstasy with no consequence
[Music]
like that let's see what you can come up
with
[Music]
Eagle two the blue leader relax try to
clear your mind empty your mind of all
fault
[Music]
and finally number one psycho Phoenix
secretary Marion crane on the lamb after
stealing 40 Grand from her employer in
order to run away with her boyfriend Sam
Loomis is overcome by exhaustion during
a heavy rainstorm traveling on the back
roads to avoid the police she stops for
the night at the ramshackle Bates Motel
and meets the polite but highly shrunk
proprietor Norman Bates a young man with
an interest in Taxidermy and a difficult
relationship with his mother starring
Anthony Perkins Janet Lee Vera Miles and
directed by Alfred Hitchcock critics say
Infamous for a shower scene but Immortal
for its contribution to the horror genre
because psycho was filmed with tact
Grace and art Hitchcock didn't just
create modern horror he validated it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]